can't hear you just just a number my
wealth is in my company because that's
how I get compensated in my iPad know
how much of your new money when in zero
because thanks already might miss a
diamond 12 million I did not put any new
money in I've walked four hundred
thousand shares and I've forgotten the
the amount but I bought for two thousand
years nothing nothing
8.4 million and nothing new all of its
in thank you madam chef thank you very
much on that note we will recess until
1:15 so I'd like to ask all the members
and our witnesses to police return
promptly at 1:15 so that we can continue
our questions thank you very much
comitia come to order
chair recognizes mr. Garrett in New
Jersey for five minutes I thank the
chair and I thank the fact we're holding
this hearing today although some may
argue that we're holding it a day late
and a dollar short number of us
requested such a hearing back in
December before we released the second
round of 350 billions of TARP the idea
being that before we authorize the
expenditure or 350 billion dollars for a
second time maybe we should know how we
spent the first one unfortunately that's
not the way we operate here in Congress
secondly I just made the point to thank
the chairman for edification for the
committee with regard to the cause of
where we're here today and he said his
opening statement that it was not
deregulation but non regulation or the
absence of regulation that would help
bring us to where we are today that is
significant because many times we have
heard from the other side of the aisle
that there was rampant deregulation
occurring over the last decade or so
opening up the marketplace to allow all
sorts of other activity to occur I
appreciate the Chairman edifying us that
it was in fact as many of us said not
deregulation but perhaps some gaps and
lack of regulation turning into some
questioning mr. blank beam I would ask
with regard to your company and your
information that you can enlighten me on
the situation with AIG some people say
that when federal government stepped in
and helped bail out AIG what they really
were doing was saving the counterparties
or saving the banks in their
relationship with AIG I wonder if you
could just sort of enlighten us as to
what your relationship is with or was
with a IJ what your position with as far
as counterparty obligations what a
dollar amounts may have been at that
point in time sure AIG was a very large
obviously very large company it was also
hat was a very large player in the in
the credit markets insuring credits we
and many people on Wall Street and many
businesses had exposures would have had
exposures would have dealt with
AIG in our dealings with AIG we were
always subject to a collateral
arrangement and so that with respect to
our dealings with AIG we were always
fully collateralized and had de minimis
or no credit risk at any given moment
because we exchange collateral so we had
outstanding positions as did most people
but we had no credit exposure because we
had collateral from them and in some
cases other kind of credit mitigant i've
heard rumors or stories in the paper
what-have-you as far as the position
dollar amount can you give us a ballpark
figure at what we were total outstanding
if you looked at the nominal amounts of
positions would have been twenty billion
dollars worth of nominal positions that
wasn't the exposure exposure was
substantially less and we exchanged
collateral I do know where the source of
the rumors were there was a New York
Times story subject to a retort that was
partially retracted that that made the
statement that AIG was being saved for
the benefit of the counterparty now to
some extent AIG had obligations to a lot
of people had they defaulted on their
obligations they would have gone
bankrupt and that would have triggered
but we it happens that an in in a
particular statement that said goldman
sachs had a huge obligation which we
immediately denied our CFO and our
earnings call said to the world that we
had no significant credit exposure to
AIG and i repeat that to you now okay
and so if you were if they were fully
collateralized and what was the I was
three cent a the point as far as the
statements made by some that federal
dollars actually went through AIG to you
would not be a correct statement correct
because they were already fully
collateralized we were collateralized if
they were collateralized and if you were
collateralized then what was a necessity
for the Federal Fed to step in at that
point to bail them out well a IG had a
lot of exposures it wasn't being driven
okay in any way by this exposures to
goldman sachs okay yeah and i put in my
time going runs quick were you hedged on
the way down as well for that we had we
had count we had a collateral yes the
answer is yes we always
had you sometimes the hedge I'm sorry
sometimes the collateral would lag and
we would stuff and we would also take
out credit insurance gets their exposure
so it was always our intention we manage
all our risks including a good credit
risk but does that does that mean help
me understand the SAP meet min 15
seconds does that mean that you can
start win on the way up and on the way
down no no no no no it just meant that
we insured we were insured against
losing money because of their default so
you did not say benefit on the on on the
fact they were collateralized on the one
hand transactions with them and if they
had gone the wrong way they would have
owed us money right we assume they pay
it but if they default it they wouldn't
pay us we insured against that default
we didn't win money from it we didn't we
wouldn't have made money voters
protected our downside okay I appreciate
that time Sam thank you thank you
several of the witnesses have said that
they have not used taxpayer money to pay
bonuses and dividends gentlemen money is
fungible don't insult our intelligence
it is a rather silly claim to say well
we just used the depositors money or the
investors money to pay the dividends and
the bonuses and then we put the
taxpayers money in our vault pending the
day when those depositors want to make a
withdrawal the issue is what dividends
and bonuses did you pay or will you pay
while you're holding taxpayer money
the Chairman correctly States taxpayers
want their money back ASAP which wha is
why it is outrageous that some of you
have paid all of you have paid dividends
or had stock repurchases you had extra
money and instead of loaning it to the
economy instead of repaying it to the
taxpayers is what you should have done
you sent it out as dividends to your
shareholders eight out of eight of you
have paid dividends since October first
seven out of eight of you have paid
dividends after you got the the tarp
money so I want you to provide a
statement on your dividend policies for
the record
but for now I'd like you to just raise
your hand unless you have adopted a
policy that prevents future dividends
and future stock repurchases until the
taxpayers are repaid please raise your
hand in less you have such a policy so
the rest I see only the first two
witnesses blank and fine and Damon have
raised their hand the rest of you have
adopted such a policy mr. Kelly do you
have a policy against paying dividends
to your common shareholders while you're
holding taxpayer money congressman we
have reduced our dividend to one I
didn't okay and you have a policy is
that a policy does anybody else have
I'll give you one set of share does
anybody other than mr. Logue have a
policy against paying dividends in
excess of one cent a share for a lot for
so long as you hold the taxpayers money
that's where we are okay so I see mr.
Lewis and the gentleman from Citicorp
raising their hands the rest of you
ought to adopt such a policy next is a
question insisted upon by three new
friends I have in Detroit I'd like you
to provide for the record a detailed
statement about planes and perks but for
now I'd like you to raise your hand if
your company currently owns or leases a
private plane well let the record show
all the hands so when up except for the
gentleman from golden Goldman Sachs
gentlemen we know that is extremely
expensive to operate these planes that
you could sell them and in there and
generate capital for your company and
that capital could be used to repay
taxpayers immediately the big show of
not buying one particular new plane
flies in the face of how you're really
flying third issue the first 254 billion
dollars of tarp money was invested and
all parties announced that this was at
par that the Treasury was getting
securities worth as much as the Treasury
was in investing the Congressional
Oversight Panel last Friday distributed
this chart which is behind me which
shows that the taxpayers were screwed to
the tune of seventy eight billion
dollars much of it by the firms
represented here
I'd like you to raise your hand if you
plan to suggest to your board of
directors that they issue additional
preferred shares and warrants to the
taxpayer to fully compensate for the
shortfall demonstrated by the by the
Congressional Oversight Panel let the
record show no hands went up and that
all the witnesses are content to leave a
situation where the taxpayers have been
under compensated to the tune of seventy
eight billion dollars I'll ask the
gentleman from Citibank particularly you
receive forty five billion in cash it's
been demonstrated I think conclusively
by the Congressional Oversight Panel
that you only delivered securities
preferred stock and warrants with the
value of twenty five and a half billion
dollars shorting us to the tune of 20 19
and a half billion dollars are you
content to just sit there and say sorry
we gave you two little securities we're
happy that we gave you so little and
we're not going to give you more now
before you answer don't tell me that the
securities could go up in value and
could be worth hundreds of billions of
dollars trust me you know if I sold you
General Motors stock today for $10 a
share you'd call that an unfair
transaction because the market says
today it's worth about three so why are
you unwilling to issue additional
securities to make the taxpayers fully
compensated congressman I have analysis
we'd like to look at the numbers and I
haven't done that I don't know where
these exactly where all these numbers
come from but that comes from the
Congressional Oversight Panel and the
hearings of last week I appreciated I
can also tell you what you asked me not
to do I am because ultimately my goal is
to make this an extremely profitable
investment for the US government I plan
to pay it back in the meantime we're
paying 3.4 billion dollars annually as
dividends on this investment mr. Barrett
of North Carolina five minutes Thank You
mr. chairman
south not north thank you gentlemen
thank you for being here today
gentlemen I believe in the power of the
free market I believe in
entrepreneurship I believe in risk
I believe in innovation but I want you
to understand and I know you do that
your decisions have real consequences
and when we stray away from making good
common-sense business decisions and
moral decisions that we put a lot of
things in jeopardy and I know you know
this but we have people in America and
people in this Congress that if you
don't get it right they're going to take
control and they're going to get it
right and that scares the fire out of me
because I believe that our free market
and our capitalistic society is at stake
and I'm not trying to be overdramatic
but it rests on you so please get it
right mr. Pandit
thank you for your your report today I
look forward to taking a look at that
and I applaud you for forgetting that I
hope that you get all 435 members that
information I keep hearing from a lot of
people that stability and consistency
certainty is what we need what can the
federal government do right now in your
opinion that can help the stability and
the certainty of the market today or is
there anything we can do congressman we
are amidst a once and many generation
economic event and it really is about
GDP and unemployment we need to arrest
that and the plans that have been talked
about so far I think are responsive we
have to stabilize housing it started
there we need to fix it there keep
people in their homes avoid foreclosures
try to get that to stabilize we need to
make sure we get credit flowing again
and that is clearly a very important
part of what the federal government and
the Federal Reserve Bank can do and we
need to create jobs I think those three
are still the goals we were pleased to
see treasurer secretary Geithner's
report yesterday but we're all awaiting
a lot more details to see exactly how
it's going to work to your point
you know the federal government has done
some things and there's there's talk
about spending this next 350 with with
secretary Geithner do we need to take a
wait-and-see approach a little more
measured approach now mr. pendant in in
say let's let some of this stuff
percolate before we commit anything else
congressman that's a very good question
and again there are no easy answers to
that let me tell you that we always deal
with economics but there is also an
issue of confidence and I don't have a
formula as to how to fix confidence we
know what we can do economically and the
confidence is up to all of us here in
this room including the Treasury
secretary and the president everybody
else and and one thing we do know about
confidence when broken you get to fixing
it really fast yeah mr. Dimon same
question whoa is there anything that you
know we can do to bring some certainty
into the market federal government it's
a combination there's no one thing but I
think very well designed fiscal
stimulation I know something got voted
on in the conference today
I can't evaluate the effectiveness of
all that because I'm not capable of
doing that but that's one piece I had
the Secretary of Treasury yesterday
spoke about if I'm gonna clearly for
different types of things greatly stay
that out which i think is will be
helpful and important financing
mortgages making the boat cheaper more
affordable and we spoke earlier today
about making mortgage modifications easy
to do and quicker the public-private
Bank and the stress testing and
additional capital of banks if these
things are done they're done quickly
coordinated consistent fairly I think
they will have a very good effect and
start to slow you know start to turn
this this around thanks sir mr. Lewis do
you believe that this tarp program has
permanently changed the face of the free
market system in the United States
well it's certainly certainly the most
unusual thing I think we've ever done in
at least in Maya almost 40 years in this
industry but I don't think it has to
I think we could have a scenario where
the economy does improve that that the
banks within the 3-year period do pay it
back and that we get back to normal so
I'm not so skeptical to say that we've
that we've turned the corner in that
poor mr. Kelly same question I would I
would say the system is not permanently
changed I think there's a number of
learnings and that we've had the worst
economic downturn since the 30s I think
there's very good learnings from this
they're complicated there's a lot of
things we've got to do I do think we
have a very good chance to to be able to
as a group as the industry to repay the
tarp money and for the taxpayers to
ultimately make a lot of money on it
guys fix this thing so we can get out of
this stuff Thank You mr. chairman
are you myself five minutes chairman
Frank initiated talking about we look
back so that we can make sure that we
can go forward Barack Obama is now the
President of the United States because
he said there should be change in
Washington and I think that there's one
thing that we have in common that is
those in the financial services
industries and those of us that sit in
Congress is that right now both of us
your industry and mine have a
credibility problem with the American
people there's enough blame there's a
lot of blame to go around but we both
have a credibility problem and that is
the kind of change that we're talking
about and when I think about this crises
that we're currently engaged in there's
some things that I think surely that we
should have done probably as members of
Congress and maybe we should say to the
American people that we did and we're
looking to get it right this time
and apologize to them for not getting it
right the first time
in regards to a lot of the investments
that was made apparently clearly there's
some things some bad investments were
made so my first question is that you
feel that the industry have anything to
apologize to the American people for
so that we can try to have some
reconciliation to move forward and gain
some credibility back does the industry
have anything that we should apologize
to the American people for because we
didn't catch this and now we're in this
terrible situation anyone it's a tough
question so let me just say that as an
industry clearly we made mistakes
whether it's leverage at least speaking
of my company at one point we had 32
times leverage whether it was in loans
that we made that we shouldn't have made
whether it was in some of the complex
instruments so I think for Morgan
Stanley's point of view you know if you
go back and play the clock over again
you definitely would do it differently I
think the entire industry to share some
of that responsibility and for that we
are sorry for it I'm especially sorry
for what's happened to shareholders and
the knock-on effect to that has been
what's happened to American people but
clearly as an industry we have
accountability and we're responsible is
much broader than just this this group
of people that we all have
responsibility I'll take that
responsibility for my firm thank you let
me move forward to try to get to this
question that I think was asked by Miss
waters earlier and yes we were talking
about I believe the underwriters fees as
when you heard that question before that
I guess internally you pay the
underwriters within your companies etc
let me extend that to say that to ask
this in when you talking about
the whether it's the FDIC or the tea lgp
program and the underwriting is there
any opportunity to have any of you
utilized any small or minority or
women-owned firms and know that in
listening to mr. McCauley he said most a
lot of folks initiated from small firms
before they got the big firms but
looking at the fees that that was paid
internally or so it appears to me
I'm one
whether that anyone has given any money
or utilized that to give it out to some
under written by small or minority-owned
firms or women-owned firms I might take
it on in our company I believe it's in
many of the companies we have minority
vendor programs who are not only tier 1
but tier 2 so we put our products and
services out for bid for whatever it
might be but I'm talking now
specifically about the top and/or the
fdic temporary liquidity guarantee
program and the fees that would be
utilized by underwrite as they are in
you know I think that mr. Pandit talked
earlier about that the money that is
legal that you know you have to by law
you have to have under underwritten my
question is you know there's also
opportunities there for it to be farmed
out to others or contracted out to other
minority firms or small firms and I was
wondering if anyone has done with any of
those fees specifically yeah and we've
done the public dollars yes we've done
that congressman Knight I don't have the
facts I'm gonna get you the facts I
believe we do that but let us get you
the information okay
I'd like to get the information from
from everyone else finally let me ask
mr. mr. Blankman you know I think that I
caught the word in your testimony that
you said you are wholesaler and
therefore you don't get into the housing
market however it would seem to me that
since housing is the and foreclosure and
keeping people in our homes is most
importantly is there anything as a as a
as a wholesaler that you and your
company can do to to make sure that we
keeping people in their homes Thank You
congressman we are not a an originator
of mortgages because we don't deal with
the consumer
however we we own a mortgage servicing
company that is responsible for
interacting on behalf of the owners of
mortgages and that is lit and servicing
and that
company has been very four-sided and
innovative in the way it's been the way
it's approached its dealing and
modifying mortgages they sure sure
Thank You mr. chairman coming from
Michigan that reports about the failure
of the Wall Street bailout to date has
caused a lot of concern there's a lot of
suffering going on in Michigan high
unemployment highest in the country
very difficult time finding credit it is
so difficult for them to get credit
despite the Wall Street bailout that
they were told would work that they are
beginning to think they're being
redlined by banks I simply bring this to
your attention without my own comment on
it the question that I do have regarding
the auto industry is we are seeing the
UAW we are seeing the auto executives we
are seeing suppliers car dealers
everyone coming together to make sure
that the American based auto industry
survives I'd like to know what your view
of the survival of the American auto
industry is and is if as stakeholders in
that process you are willing to help
ensure that the restructuring process is
successful well congressman we have and
clearly not just my firm we have
relationships with the Big Three
automakers we have loans on our books to
them one of the things that hopefully
we'll be able to do as markets open up
for them as we've done in the past raise
either debt money for more prefer or
find foreign investors who will put
money in with them so from my
perspective we couldn't be any more
focus and committed not only in spirit
but on our balance sheet congressman
we're at closer to the customer end of
that situation we finance and do
business with many of the 20,000
different auto dealers there are in the
nation we are buying about 1.5 billion
dollars of consumer auto paper a month
in our company and we view that as good
credit and helps hardworking Americans
buy cars
I would say that number one we're
working with Louis Jim as we speak to
convert their debt to equity secondly
that we like automobile loans and
actually in January they were up seven
percent over January of those seven wait
mr. Moore of Kansas for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman
I have a series of questions I'd like to
ask and ask each of you to respond and
start if we could with Wells Fargo mr.
Stumpf at the end and just move this way
if you would please
how much taxpayer money did your company
receive in the past five months number
two is how much salary did you receive
in 2008 and how much of any bonus or
other financial consideration did you
receive I'd like to go down the line
with those two questions please
my we received twenty five billion
dollars my compensation in 2008 was
embarrassed I think it's a ton 50 I
can't remember the exact number let's
say AR and $50,000 and as far as bonus
our company our board of directors makes
that decision in February regarding 2008
but there's no mystery there unless we
reach at least a 15 percent return
internal rate of return or 235 earnings
per share
we don't qualify and we didn't make
either those so there will be no bonus
thank you sir mr. Pandit
what's Citigroup yes congressman we
received 45 billion dollars of tarp
money my compensation for the year 2008
was my salary which is a million dollars
I received no bonus and as I stated
earlier I plan to take $1 a year in
salary and no bonus until you return to
profitability thank you sir Morgan
Stanley mr. Mack a ten billion in tarp
funds $800,000 in salary and zero bonus
thank you sir mr. Logue State Street
Corporation
congressman we received two billion
dollars in tarp funds my salary is one
dollars and my bonus is zero thank you
sir
Bank of America mr. Lewis 2008 15
billion in tarp money million 5 salary
no incentive thank you sir
mr. Kelly Bank of New York Mellon 3
billion in tarp money congressman and my
salary is 1 million dollars and 0 bonus
thank you sir mr. demon JPMorgan mr.
Carter I got 20 we got twenty five
billion dollars in tarp money my salary
is 1 million dollars and there was no
bonus paid for 2008 thank you sir and
mr. banking Goldman Sachs but tarp money
six hundred thousand dollars in salary
no bonus thank you sir
how much salary again start this and
this time we'll go back the other way
how much salary we receive in 2009 has
that been determined and what do you
expect to receive if any in the way of
bonuses in 2009 2009 salaries still to
$600,000 and we're a long way from Bonus
Time
ok mr. Newman my salary is still 1
million dollars and we're a long way
from bonus time to instead of going
through all this is there anybody whose
salary will have changed from last year
yes sir mr. penny I've told my board
I'll take a dollar a year in salary
thank you sir anybody else ok will I'd
like to start now to begin down here if
you would please
with the goldman sachs and ask will you
expect that your company will be able to
pay back taxpayer pilot funds by 2012
it's my hope to do that well before that
markets are uncertain you think if the
my if it can be we will thank you sir
mr. Goodman yes mr. Kelly yes Louis yes
having trouble seeing farther than there
yes yes sir yes all right yes and yes
we're Wells Fargo
very good Thank You mr. chairman thanks
to the general panet
the gentleman yields back mr. lance from
New Jersey is recognized for five
minutes
thank you very much
and good afternoon to all of you
gentlemen mr. Stanton and the entire row
as a follow-up to the question that was
just asked how many of you would be able
to pay back the tarp funding early and
not related to the three years but
perhaps early and I know there may be
legislation that's being written so that
you don't have a penalty for paying back
this money early so how many of you
could expect to pay it back early in
Wells Fargo's case that would depend on
the credit markets more than anything
else mr. bandit congressman we're all
dependent on markets market conditions
as soon as possible given that I think
the markets have been proved we think
maybe not the entire amount about 2012
but some portion of it prior to that
Thank You mr. mica congressman I would
agree with my colleagues that will
depend on the markets hopefully we will
be able to give it back prior to 2012
thank you I would agree markets in the
economy and would like nothing better
than to pay it back early and I agree
with my colleagues pay it back earlier
and that would have to just be in
consultation with our regulators and the
Secretary of Treasury thank you same and
the expectation present expectation is
that it would be early thank you and
following up on a line of questioning
from congresswoman Maloney earlier in
the hearing and this is to you mr. Lewis
and I recognize your bank of america and
not merrill lynch and there was a great
deal of pressure on Bank of America to
merge with Merrill Lynch but we are all
disturbed about the level of bonuses
from Merrill Lynch was Bank of America
aware of the contractual nature of those
bonuses yes as we got a new diligence we
saw them the contracts are yes and are
those contracts a matter of public
record or can they be made a matter of
public record I don't know the answer to
that but but out there worked as I
mentioned they were two or three that
were very very large and were
contractual obligations of Merrill Lynch
I certainly would be interested in I
would imagine the committee would be
interested in what m4
information is available as a matter of
public record regarding that I believe
that tarp funding is of course fungible
and that from our perspective those
bonuses are really some tarp funds now
you state quite accurately in your
testimony that is a practical matter we
cannot tell you whether the next loan we
make is funded by tarp or from preferred
stock placed with other investors etc
and I certainly respect that at that
point mr. Lewis but from the perspective
of those of us in Congress we are deeply
concerned about the level of bonuses of
Merrill Lynch and I would hope that yeah
in your responsibilities that you could
impress upon your colleagues who have
come to Bank of America from Merrill
Lynch to an even greater extent than you
have done already that I think it is the
consensus of Congress that this is
precisely what the American people find
objectionable with the first portion of
tarp so we we've owned mill now for 42
days yes sir and things have changed
we're in charge now yeah thank you thank
you very much mr. Lewis I yield back the
balance of my time
I thank the gentleman and gentleman from
Massachusetts is recognized for five
minutes
Thank You sheriff all right after the
budget discussion we just have five
minutes or one more he's on the
committee of house administration thank
you a million a minute Mike gentlemen
you've been asked a lot of questions and
you're on it seemingly answering them
honestly to me I have a couple of more
detailed questions of all of you just by
showing hands how many of your banks
either directly or indirectly and by
indirectly I mean by loaning money to
people that you knew would be using this
money to invest in credit default swaps
how many of you are engaged in that none
of you we engage in credit default swaps
but when you're asking the question are
we lending money for them to do that I'd
have to come back and give you specifics
I cannot tell you did you how many of
you directly engaged in purchasing or
investing in credit default swaps how
many of you directly or indirectly
engaged in credit and CD
how many of you had a very good recorder
but recording raise hands doesn't work
so we'll need some oral we can fill that
in later and and how many of you are in
how many of your banks had or currently
have special investment vehicles those
off-the-books somehow unregulated
subsidiaries of the bank or sister
corporations we have SPD's okay so
basically all of most of you engaged in
all or at least some of the activities
that actually created this crisis in my
opinion because every one of those
activities especially the SIV s
especially the SIV s to me I think
they're illegal
I cannot believe no one's prosecuted you
on this but then again we've had no
prosecutorial action whatsoever the last
administration and the new
administration has a little time to
figure this out we'll find out whether
anybody really cares how can possibly
any regulated bank have something on its
books that's totally unregulated that
fall intents and purposes it's the same
thing the bank does
that's real lawyers the answer and my
hope is that you will be answering those
questions in court someday we'll find
out later on but basically you come to
us today on your bicycles after buying
Girl Scout cookies and helping out
mother Theresa telling us we're sorry we
didn't mean it we won't do it again
trust us well I have some people in my
constituency that actually robbed some
of your banks and they say the same
thing they're sorry they didn't mean it
they won't do it again just let them out
do you understand that this is a little
difficult for most of my constituents to
take that you learned your lesson and
it's all the same people doing this the
same people who created s IVs who
created CDOs who created credit default
swaps that never existed a few years ago
you created them you created the mess
we're in and no not the only ones don't
get me wrong you just happen to be the
ones here today
I can't wait to get the credit rating
agencies here someday again and now
you're saying sorry trust us and by the
way we don't even want the money
interesting no one's ever come to me and
say you must take billions of dollars
and as I heard it earlier you have an
option basically they said you have to
capitalize better because we no longer
trust your books you can either take
this money and do it or you can do it on
your own if you don't want the money you
can give it back you just have to come
up with the capital that's I understand
then if you can't do it I think many of
us would be happy to change that law you
have to understand I don't really have a
question but I was told that I can use
the five minutes because the questions I
have you have the answer them and you're
gonna continue to answer them and that's
all well and good the problem I have is
that honestly none of us America doesn't
trust you anymore
I for one between myself and my various
campaigns in my own personal business
stuff I get a lot of money to put in
banks I don't have one single penny in
any of your banks not one not one
because I don't want my money put into
CEOs and credit default swaps and making
humongous bonuses me personal until that
changes none of us really believe I was
set none of us I don't believe anything
will change until you change the people
who brought you in to s IVs who was the
brilliant person who came and said let's
do credit default swaps find him firing
tell me to fire them get out of CDOs
start loaning the money that we gave you
get it on the street and don't say oh
well we're not using that money for
bonuses come on
money is all of a sudden not fungible in
your entity it's fungible everywhere
else but not in your entities get our
money out on the street and if you don't
want to give it back don't come here and
tell me you can't yes you can as long as
you live up to the requirements that are
put on you now
in the new world that you created and we
have to clean up with that mr. Chairman
I yield back the remainder of my time
the gentleman from North Korea mr.
McHenry Thank You mr. chairman and thank
you all for testifying today as a
taxpayer and I guess now a stockholder
we appreciate it
there's been a lot of discussion and
debated hey Paul dodgy gentlemen start
the clock over the gentleman is
recognized
Thank You mr. chairman there's been a
lot of debate here in Congress about
what the tarp funds went to was it
consumer lending or was it safety and
soundness there's been a lot of debate
and part of the reason why is the former
secretary of the treasury did a great
sales job and said if we obligate
taxpayer dollars for your financial
institutions whether you liked it or
you're bored liked it or your investors
liked it or not that it would increase
consumer lending it was nothing more
than a sales job as I think is pretty
evident but my question to you and we
could just go alphabetical order just
yes or no is your first obligation to
your depositors to your board to your
investors is your first obligation the
safety and soundness of your institution
mr. blinken I think so yes yes safety
zones absolutely Safety's honest
safety onus yes yes thank you I think we
have completely resolved whether or not
the tarp funds were for you to simply
lend or for the safety and soundness of
our financial system okay I have a
question mr. Blankman secretary
Geithner's outlined his tarp 2 proposal
and again we just have a outline what
are your general thoughts on this
proposal and will it work
again I just seen the outline and I
probably haven't read it even as closely
as you have given Mike given that my
traveling in these past couple of days
well the Train is a much more efficient
way to travel relaxing and you can read
the my feeling is that they're committed
to trying a lot of things and it's that
they're taking a lot of initiatives and
I think here there's nothing ideological
there are a number of different things
like insurance like an aggregator Bank
like extending credit for other
institutions and I think they're trying
they're trying all of them in some way
shape or form and I think that that's
actually what the situation kind of
calls for because we're not really sure
what will work but I think they'll be in
a position to emphasize those that are
getting traction are you comfortable
with more transparency and disclosure of
where the funds go and how they're used
well I heard the intent and of course
we've seen the outline but certainly all
signs now are that they're really
committed to transparency ok mr. diamond
what are your thoughts on the new
Geithner proposal I think the important
part is that all of these things be done
well the Devils in the details and how
they get executed some we know about the
fiscal stimulus plan got passed today
I'm not an expert than that it didn't
get passed yet I mean I mean the
conferees agreed to it and I think the
TAF plan will work and serve a purpose I
think guarantees will work and serve a
purpose I don't know yet the mortgage
plans it's important that take place
both modifications and you know make it
cheaper for Americans and I've got to
see more detail on the stress tests and
capital injections I do think of all
these things that's done well and
properly it will have a very big
beneficial effect on this country and in
the opening up to CMBS you all agree if
you could both touch on that is that
healthy I think that helps yes that
necessary mr. Kelly there's no question
that the real estate market is under
great commercial real estate markets and
retail stress and it's going to continue
to be and will probably be worse that
year from now than today so I've heard
certainly heard from a number of real
estate executives that they need access
to funds and I would think that
would be helpful okay mr. Lewis you know
I just live in the suburbs of Charlotte
your institutions vital to us as was is
Wachovia now Wells the question I have
to you is about transparency and
disclosure I think your institutions
been hammered in the on the street
because of a lack of transparency and
disclosure as to what the government
funds are for what is what is the
reasoning the government has given you
these extraordinary sums of money would
you be comfortable with greater
transparency and disclosure of the
decision-making of how government
obligates funds yes I don't know I don't
know exactly what you're talking about
in terms of what more needs to be done
but of course as of use of the tarp
money with voluntary said that each
month we're going to show what we're
doing with it
how we're using it each week I meet with
my executives to talk about what what
more can we do so we're very focused on
lending money well know that the
disclosure of how government makes the
decision on giving you funds I'm asking
from a government perspective should we
disclose more there correct I think I
have but if you want more you certainly
can have it the gentleman's time has
expired
and the gentleman Missouri is recognized
Thank You mr. chairman
gentleman since last October the
taxpayers have injected more than 300
billion dollars into the financial
system to stabilize key institutions
including yours with the exception of
Citibank who has at least made an effort
at honest disclosure the rest of you
haven't seen fit to follow suit the
American people are now your partners
and your partners have a right to know
where their money went went so on behalf
of the taxpayer who now own a portion of
your institutions what did you do with
the money and our start with mr. stones
away the he's City
let's stop thank you another question
with respect to go buddy with the money
yeah what did you do with the money well
we have about 100 billion dollars of
capital in our company this 70 25
billion added to that and as I stated my
testimony we use those funds in the
funds of our other investors to run our
business on behalf of our communities
our team members our customers and our
shareholders last year we made a three
billion dollar profit doing that and
we've had a long history of using our
capital to advance the kinds of
businesses we do making loans is a big
part of it we make money when we sure
we've modified seven hundred and six
thousand mortgages in the last year and
a half 22% of all the mortgages that
were reported by the industry of
modifications okay one of the most
frustrating aspects of this crisis that
every time we think we understand how
bad things are in the financial sector
something that one of you failed to
disclose comes to light and the
situation gets worse so I want all of
you to look us and give it to us
straight and tell this committee
how many more potential losses are out
there what do you what do you see on the
horizon what do you what are you
forecasting well it's to me it's all
about jobs I started out in this
industry 35 years ago as a collector in
the same for things that affected a
consumer delinquency are the same for
today it's the death divorce a
unscheduled medical payment and a job
loss nothing's happened to the first
three job lost is the key so this is all
about jobs and if if you can tell me
what's gonna happen unemployment I PI
can tell you what's gonna happen
in in credit but I think it we're still
having a very challenging time and I
commend you and the rest of Congress who
are working on ways to help get this
economy going with jobs and we want to
participate in that helping you with
that thank you for that response
depending what
you see in the forecast congressman I
have to agree with the fact that when it
comes to consumer banks and commercial
banks profits and losses are completely
tied to GDP and unemployment that's what
determines where things are one thing
that's different about this cycle is
that it's not tied in the same way as it
was before which means that it becomes
difficult to forecast completely having
said that anything we can do to be on
the plan to keep people employed and
increase them out of employment can only
help us the do you envision credit being
freed up I mean I just had a group of
commercial developers come to my office
and say they cannot build any new
developments because they cannot they
don't have access to credit that when
does that change everything you're doing
the plan that Secretary of Treasury
talked about yesterday all of these are
steps to help increase the flow of
credit in the US economy we're doing
everything we can and as you pointed out
clearly we have made an extreme effort
to account for every dollar of tarp
money that we received and we're
tracking it we're gonna do our part
thank you for your response mr. Mack
what what do you see in the forecast for
the next well it's not unlike what my
colleagues to the left have said the
only thing I would add to that if you go
back into right after the failure of
Lehman Brothers in September and into
December we're finally beginning to see
the capital markets open up where we can
raise money for corporations to help
them invest in their business we're
beginning to see investors come in where
they will invest in businesses we're
doing that but again we're very small to
consumer business we'd be Emily okay
thank you
let me say I think we probably get two
more questions in before we need people
need to go to vote it's the French vote
think of extra time we will be coming
back there were three votes so gentlemen
I appreciate this I think this has been
very important General in Minnesota mr.
Paulson for five minutes and we get one
more round on this side Thank You mr.
chairman with some of the retroactive
rules for tarp recipients and also more
pending stabilization now programs from
the Treasury and the Fed that are yet to
come
and the uncertainty now about future
regulatory reform I'm just wondering how
concerned are you or are you very
concerned that those factors or these
factors are going to potentially
drastically discourage injection of
private capital I mean real private
capital into your institutions that
really could help you shore up your
balance sheets rather than the
government providing that capital I mean
how concerned are you about that
which retroactively changes you
referring to I'm just saying in terms of
like the the retroactive rules that have
gone forward the pending stabilization
programs coming forward you know
uncertain about new regulatory reforms I
mean how concerned are you about those
issues addressing private capital coming
into your institutions right now as
opposed to sitting back and waiting for
these other things to take place well
they've created they've certainly
created some uncertainty that's not
there and so that's a deterrence on the
other hand you have to balance it
against the fact that there's some
things that are need to be fixed and so
any uncertainty is disliked certainty is
disliked by the market on the other hand
we know that we have to make changes so
we're going to go ahead and have these
changes and maybe I can just follow up
mr. chair you know some of you have
already said you feel that you've not
been given a very clear directive you
know from Congress or the government how
to use the money that has been provided
that's come directly from the tarp funds
you know aside from that directive what
other recommendations you know do you
have for the government or if your
future disbursements now of those funds
either to your companies or the other
recipients that may get them in terms of
just good advice to make sure it flows
more smoothly well frankly I don't I
think I think the issue is more the
economy and in creating demand than any
one other single item as I mentioned the
lending money is at the core of what a
commercial bank does and we don't make
we don't optimize our profits unless we
lend money so we need to be have more
demand and and the critical thing there
is pretty common to turn around and
maybe I can ask one other question as we
consider the regulations for the
financial markets because we're going to
be doing that now to sort of get rid of
the crisis that we're in prevent another
one from happening or deepening this
crisis actually what are the largest
concerns about over-regulating going
down the roads of sarbanes-oxley in
terms of moving in that direction and
stepping too far you know what we're
intending to be helpful but actually it
could be very harmful there's anything
specific you can draw out that we should
be very cautious of
actually I think my main concern around
compensation for instance is it's okay
to to do the things that are being
talked about at the at the very top but
if you start to go too low in the
organization you will run off-key palate
or key talent to our foreign competitors
is that a shared view I mean among
others yes it's one of our greatest
worries yes there's many businesses that
were in that are commissioned base for
example and if we limit across the board
or whatever we could lose some of the
most productive people and some of the
most important parts of our business if
it's widely dispersed Thank You mr.
chair I yield back
because I'm gonna ask you to spin ready
I understand the argument about front
competition it is been my impression
that people here have generally been
better compensated than people in a lot
of these other countries so I would I
would ask you to submit to me some
course national comparisons I'm frankly
skeptical from what I've seen that
they're paying so much more in other
places certainly not in your level so I
would be interested in in in those costs
national comparisons you're gonna have
to prove to me that you really wish
there if there's some motivation
Jim California thank you very much mr.
chairman for holding this hearing and I
want to thank all of CEOs for coming
here one of the questions that I have a
lot of hearing the hearings a lot of you
indicated that you have a responsibility
to the stockholders well I agree that
you have the responsibility towards your
stockholders well we have a
responsibility to the American people
and that's why we're having this hearing
right now is the American people right
now lack trust and confidence in the
banking industry especially with what's
going on right now and I want to ask a
couple of the questions one is how do
you feel about the bailout do you feel
that the bailout was necessary any one
of you
I didn't necessarily think it was
necessary at the time but I think um and
this was said at the time they were
looking ahead at an emerging recession
that was going to get worse and for
Prudential reasons it was necessary for
the systemic and safety and soundness
and a subsequent subsequent events born
out
I think it has provided safety and
soundness and taking some of the risk
away from the system anyone else want to
attempt to answer
I actually agree I I know at the time we
did not feel like we needed the 15
billion but I think in light of the
severity of the recession and in light
of the speed in which it the current
economy deteriorated I think we have
lent more money because we had to talk
funds and that level of capital well
apparently the consumers out there feel
that there hasn't been enough money that
had been laid out lend out there's a lot
of small businesses in my area and
throughout variety of different areas
right now they can't obtain loans right
now don't have access and even
developers I know that my colleague just
asked that question a while ago why is
it that they don't have access to credit
right now and why isn't it available for
small businesses and developers because
we need to turn this economy around and
if they can't employ and can't get the
money and you're for somehow reviewing
and extending before you make any kind
of decisions you're hurting us at the
same time can any one of you answer why
not well I would say that the single
biggest factor of both the small
business and and consumers particularly
into real estate is the declining home
values and loan-to-value issues with
that a small business usually most of
the equity that a small business owner
has is his home equity and as those as
this those values come down you have
loan-to-value issues anyone else want to
answer that let me ask another question
a lot of you said earlier that part of
the problem has been the credit line
well a lot of the problems that came out
and the credit lines that were offered
and credit cards that were given out
most of you are guilty of that all of
you that offered a lot of these credit
cards to many individuals students
student loans others that went out in
different areas I know
my child you know during that paradigm
she's an adult now got a little thing
you know apply for credit cards now the
credit cards have led to a lot of the
problems because you're going to end up
losing your the ones that made the
mistake in offering and giving those
credit cards you should be responsible
the American people and the taxpayer
shouldn't be responsible for the
mistakes you did and going out and
trying to get so many consumers to tie
into credit cards how do we answer and
how do we deal with your problems in
trying to attract many individuals to
get into the credit cards
I know all you want to make a profit you
do make a profit by going to individuals
that are applying for these credit cards
these are students these are a lot of
our kids that are solicited by your
industry to apply and yet you know the
interest rates goes up it continues to
go up on them some of them that started
some of them can't even buy a car some
of them later on II end up wanting to
buy a home but it's the credit cards and
you're the ones and we're the ones that
have you to bail out because of what
you've done in the loss is there anyone
would like to attempt that let me ask
another question then some of you
mentioned best practices what do you
mean by best practice statement and what
needs to be done most you say you follow
best practices well I'm not aware of
what exactly people have said the best
practices from our point of view is in
every discipline we're in so in risk
management as an example to make sure
that we have an independent risk
management that reports to the CEO and
chairman and not to some trading group
that would be an example of best
practices so that is one I think if all
these firms had had that established
there's a possibility some of this
wouldn't have been as bad as it ended up
there anytime we have to vote we're
gonna come back after the vote or be
about twenty minutes I thank you for
staying with us we are now in recess
until there is a dis about two more five
minute folks
we will now turn to the gentlemen of
Carolina mr. chairman thank